Chris what should the Giants do with the
number of two overall pick well there's
two ways I mean is to me okay I mean you
look at it like this okay if they have a
quarterback that's on their board that
is okay they have them with a grade next
to him that says he's a franchise
quarterback that can be you know
multiple Pro Bowls and a handful all-pro
teams or whatever then you drop that
quarterback at number two if that guy
falls to you and if there's two of them
let's say if it's donal Dan Allen then
you take him it's for the better good of
the organization for the next 10 to 12
years but if you're waffling on that and
you're not sold on either one of those
guys or whoever falls to you at two
don't just take a quarterback because
you want to take a quarterback and
you're the number two pick then from
there I would go say Quan Berkeley
because say Quan Berkeley is special he
is the best player in the draft and if
you're going okay now we didn't get our
quarterback well obviously we're going
with Eli Manning then for another year
or two so go all in with Eli get him say
Quan Barclay him with Odell Beckham jr.
Evan Engram sterling Shepherd in that
defense that we already know has a lot
of talent on it I just think that sets
them up to be a legit playoff flash
Super Bowl contender next year right
away because Berkeley is the type of
talent Dan in my opinion that's like he
can be in the conversation for the best
offensive player in the sport next year
when did we turn on running backs when
did we get nervous on drafting him yeah
that is a really good I'm going to say
it was towards the late 90s early 2000s
is when it started to change a little
bit because we got to see some other
guys to priests homes of the world these
other people that weren't necessarily
top picks in the draft for coming into
the NFL and tearing it up and kicking
butt and I think that's when Bella check
some of these other coaches realized wow
there's a lot of guys running backs
growing on trees and we've seen Alvin
Kamara and what he could do and Kareem
hun who led the NFL in rushing as a
third-round pick and the year before
that Jordan
Howard was second in the NFL rushing and
he was a fourth round pick and he got
Alfred Morris right with the Redskins he
was a six round pick he was in the top
five in Russian two times so I think
that's where the D value of the running
back came about but Barclays is a
special special running back he is a
face of the franchise old-school type
running back for me Dan like that
million-dollar smile unbelievable skill
set like Walter Payton bo Jackson Tony
Dorsett you know
face to the franchise type running back
and he's special I know that we look at
paying you know you want to get your
quarterback there if you can get a
franchise quarterback and you getting
four you know that those that rookie
salary and contract then you can build
around him that's what Seattle did the
window of opportunity is closed on
Seattle everybody else is sort of
looking can we get that guy and we got
him under contract for the next five
years with favorable numbers you know
and that's why I think everybody wants
to go all-in and try to they they think
that these guys are franchise
quarterbacks but let's look at the odds
though Chris how many of these
quarterbacks would you say in ten years
from now are still playing our starters
yeah their starters I mean really
realistically it'll be two or three of
the group I would say that you know just
apply the numbers on that now they all
they all have interesting things but
yeah I would say two or three best best
quarterback is the best one for me is
Josh Allen he's he is the one to me that
of course him and Lamar Jackson had the
highest ceiling and I think to Lamar I
mean and Josh Allen I think he's got
other than Josh Rosen I think he has the
highest floor to you know I'll say this
bin you know I listen he has special
elite traits right and the first round
is about people who can do elite things
well Alan has elite size elite
athleticism for that size and of course
the elite arm strength and I know
everybody's talked about all the
completion percentage well you know I've
watched all these guys I mean you know
guys like Sam Darnell the Baker may feel
they get to throw ten
a game behind the line of scrimmage and
they go ten for ten and you can watch
ten games of Josh Allen and knock see
ten screens total I mean so it's right
there that's ten percentage completion
points not to have it the fact that he
had no receivers no offensive line and
he played in my own Wyoming where it was
like 20 degrees and 40 mile-per-hour
winds every game so that's not
necessarily gonna help your completion
percentage too but Josh Allen is the guy
for me guys okay I got to go back to
something you said yeah the highest
floor right what is that I've heard the
the highest ceiling but you now we just
raised them I raised the roof you raised
the floor so explain that to me
is that at least downsize that you've
raised the floor so he's not going to
the basement
exactly exactly right yeah I just I have
a hard time believing Josh Allen who has
the highest Wonderlic school route of
all these guys was in a pro office and
then has all this skillset and we've
seen improvements to his mechanics
already in the combine in his pro day to
where yes I say the floor the bus
potentials not there same with Josh
Rosen like Josh Rosen you know I don't
look at it and go oh he's gonna totally
blow up if anything happens with Josh
Rosen it might just be injury related
but he's a good decision maker he's and
I'm unbelievable thrower the football
he's accurate he's got timing he's good
in the pocket all those things so that's
why I say those two guys have the
highest for firm a nice floor that's a
new right yeah I'm glad I gave you
something new today okay here's the
final question for Chris Sims on loan
from Pro Football Talk if I go back in
the 2016 NFL Draft right and I you can
take Gulf whence Bosa Ezekiel Elliott
Jalen Ramsey now I can remove golf and
Wentz from this and just say you got the
third pick overall how's that you got
the third pick you want to go Bosa
Ezekiel Elliott Jalen Ramsey oh that is
a great question okay so Bosa Ezekiel
Elliott and Jim they are phenomenal I
mean these are Hall of Fame potential
type guys we're talking about yeah yeah
I know I'm talking it out so I haven't
figured it out
like their floor is high floor is really
high therefore almost it's that ceiling
level I mean the best quarterback in
football I think about how to pick one I
would probably go Joey Bosa that's
really tough to say but looking at it
and I'm taking it just all into account
with his ecology and off the field okay
his hard running style all the car
crashes he gets Jalen Ramsey's
phenomenal I mean I have a man crush on
him but I think Joey Bosa when I look at
it the position he plays the value at
that position how good he is and then
the way his body is set up for me to be
really good at that position for a long
long time and having the little position
versatility I think I would go Bosa but
man that's a tough one stop in the
studio sometime here we'd love doing
have you have any home visit well let me
know you know invite me up I'll be up
there in a few weeks you know it's that
time of the month for me to come up and
visit so just let me know your nickname
is that just did it be a dispenser well
thank you buddy and so anybody be good
guy Chris Simms
NBC Sports pro football time for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]